I know you're dating yeah you're dating
so like are you getting married and do
you want to tell us now you know what
not to get weird but I think that also
it's important to say this especially to
our younger fans and younger generations
of women I I come from the Bible Belt in
Oklahoma very proudly so but with that
means that you're supposed to get
married to have 2.5 kids and live in the
picket and you know white picket fence
house and I didn't I didn't choose that
for my life I had other goals and and
and at first it was always a shame like
I shouldn't tell people that maybe I'm
not sure about having children or even
maybe getting married and I've had great
men in my life I've got a great one
right now marriage might be the deal it
might but it's never what's been my it
hasn't been what's defined me or driven
me and for a long time I was shameful
about her
[Applause]
yes people always think you were gay
people thought I was gay forever I've
had some boyfriends to make me wish I
[Laughter]
far as capable go you're not gonna have
a child and it's almost like Oh selfish
but I take care of a lot of kid I have
many cousins I have God children I take
care of and this is also important to
say as an adopted child if I ever want
to if I have that so desire one day and
I wake up and I say maybe I missed the
boat or maybe I want to do that there's
been so many great examples of women
who've done that and I would I would
just adopt a child there's many clear
one your pick like my mom just got stuck
with you like your parents yeah that's
like really cool special feeling and
I've always known it about my adoption
and you know my family they're all
chemical engineers and real tall and you
know they della thing I got a thing and
they should never sing actually ever but
I don't do math but we learn from each
other you know
that's awesome great I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this